me han llegado muchas peticiones para
explicar o enseñar lo que es el teorema
del valor medio así que hagámoslo en
este vídeo así que este será el teorema
teorema del valor
y medio y tengo muchos pensamientos
encontrados respecto a este teorema
porque parece muy fácil pero te te darás
cuenta de que no es obvio probarlo pero
la idea es bastante sencilla y la razón
por la que tengo pensamientos
encontrados es porque espero que lo veas
pero la intuición la intuición de este
teorema es muy obvia pero se apegan
tanto a los libros de cálculo que
realmente no no te dicen para qué o cómo
se intuye esto y solo y esto solo
confunde a la gente así que con un poco
de suerte este vídeo aclarará todas esas
ideas y estoy ansioso de ver que pienses
que es realmente fácil así que qué dice
este teorema déjenme hacer unos dibujos
hagamos una explicación visual primero
ok creo que voy a utilizar el magenta
para esto así que si este es el eje x
y digamos que este es el eje y
ok y digamos que tengo una función fx
déjeme pintarla déjenme dibujar fx no sé
de algunas formas
cualquiera que yo pinté es buena y
digamos si ésta es mi fx voy a ponerle
ciertas condiciones por ejemplo primero
tiene que ser continua y también tiene
que ser derivable o diferenciable
también se le puede decir y sé que
muchos de ustedes probablemente se
asusten desde cuando escuchen estas
palabras suena como lo que diría un
matemático y eso suena bastante
abstracto continuo significa que está
curva está conectada que que realmente
la podemos recorrer de un trazo y aquí
las condiciones tenemos que hacerlas por
supuesto sobre un intervalo cerrado que
este es otro término matemático que
suele por ejemplo decimos que un
intervalo cerrado es digamos digamos
esto todo esto es un intervalo digamos
aquí está no sabemos cuáles puede ser
menos 5 quién sabe no y este digamos por
aquí es b vamos a ponerle justo aquí
digamos que se vea entonces cuando
hablamos de un intervalo cerrado de que
una función está definida en un
intervalo cerrado significa que la
función debe estar definida en cada
punto entre a y b
y que además la función debe estar
definida tanto en a como en vez si se
refiere un intervalo abierto a b
significa que debe estar definida en
todos los puntos entre a y b pero no
necesariamente en a y b así que vamos a
pedirle que sea definida en en un
intervalo cerrado a coma b y sus
notaciones está con corchetes
es decir repito esto es que tiene que
estar definida en todos los x desde a
ave incluyendo a y b y si hubiese
escrito un intervalo abierto lo
escribiríamos de esta forma que
significa todos los números entre a y b
pero sin incluir los extremos así que
por ahora ignoraremos esto
volviendo al teorema del valor medio ya
sabes es pero lo que significa continuo
dibujaré lo que vamos a pensar a lo
mejor en una función discontinua no por
ejemplo ésta
este es un ejemplo de una función
digamos y déjenme poner los ejes
en otro color es en esa línea estuvo muy
mal
digamos este es nuestro eje y y este es
nuestro eje x entonces
en esta función es continua hasta este
punto pero de repente hay este salto
esta desconexión digamos eso hace que la
función sea discontinua o que no sea
continua así que la función en este caso
tiene que ser continua y derivable que
significa diferenciable también se le
dice significa que la podemos calcular
su derivada en cualquier punto ok
entonces la función es diferenciable y
qué más significa bien significa que si
representas esta gráfica de esta función
también la puedo hacer de forma continua
y en efecto en este vídeo les enseñaré
que una función que bueno les daré un
ejemplo de una función que es continua
pero no es derivable y por ello no
podemos aplicar el teorema del valor
medio de todas formas la mayoría de las
funciones con las que trabajamos cumplen
con las tres condiciones a menos de que
esté resolviendo límites que hace que
esto se venga abajo en algunas de esas
hipótesis en fin vamos a suponer que
esta función cumple todo esto y lo que
nos dice es que si tomamos la pendiente
media entre el punto b
pero bueno a ver primero qué es la
pendiente la pendiente media entre el
punto a y b en realidad es la distancia
en vertical que recorre la función entre
todo lo que avanzamos en el eje x verdad
digamos y este es la distancia
horizontal para pensar que esta es la
distancia y esta es la distancia
vertical
y este el punto de acá arriba digamos es
el coma
efe
por otro lado este punto de aquí será el
b
efe db
muy bien así que cuál es la pendiente
media entre a y b pues simplemente será
la distancia recorrida en vertical entre
la distancia recorrida en horizontal
verdad entonces cuanto hemos subido
cuánto cuánta distancia recorrimos entre
fvf de a pues simplemente es la altura
verdad la altura que hemos recorrido
y entonces tenemos efe dv
cfda que es la altura recorrida lo
recorrido en la posición vertical entre
ve - a que es lo recorrido en la
dirección horizontal verdad entonces
digamos si trazamos una línea que pase
por estos dos puntos
déjenme hacerlo en azul
tenemos esta línea así que la pendiente
entre estos dos puntos es la pendiente
media y que es lo que nos dice el
teorema del valor medio dice que si fx
está definida en un intervalo cerrado
vea a ve que si es continua y que además
es diferenciable entonces podemos
encontrar un punto c donde la derivada
es decir f prima de c
lo escribo sé dónde
efe prima de ce es igual a esta cosa de
la pendiente media entonces no debería
haberlo escrito aquí pero bueno que nos
está diciendo lo que nos está diciendo
es que si encontramos una función
continua
diferenciable definida en un intervalo
cerrado existe un c tal que bueno además
se tiene que estar entre a y b
en entre los dos puntos pero punto es
que existe es ese donde la pendiente o
la derivada es idéntica a la pendiente
de esta línea que conecta a los dos
puntos iniciales perdón al punto inicial
y al punto final verdad entonces digamos
vamos a encontrar un punto donde se le
parezca está pendiente que ya hemos
calculado por supuesto vamos a verlo de
forma geométrica verdad digamos quizás
en este punto aquí donde lo he dibujado
poco exacto entonces digamos que la
pendiente es más o menos así justo así y
aunque no sabemos cómo es esta función
analíticamente visualmente podemos ver
que en este punto ce digamos la derivada
en este punto c
aunque digamos este s la derivada ahí
pues se parece a la que la pendiente
media entonces
digamos que en realidad estás rectas son
paralelas así que f prima de se va a ser
igual a la pendiente media sobre el
total verdad y esta curva probablemente
tenga otro punto donde la pendiente sea
igual a la pendiente media digamos puede
parecerme por ejemplo este punto de aquí
que he dibujado no
a lo mejor puede parecerse digamos
y verlo de esta forma recuerden que las
líneas en realidad deberían ser
paralelas ok y espero que todo esto
tenga sentido para ti otra forma de
pensar es
digamos déjenme dibujar una nueva
gráfica para asegurarme que que estamos
acertando en la idea entonces vamos a
dibujar mi posición como una función del
tiempo que esto es algo bastante útil en
el mundo real así que digamos y estos
son mis ejes x i
ok entonces esto nos regresa a la idea
original de lo que es una derivada de
verdad digamos si esto está en tiempo y
arriba es la posición no importa digamos
entonces si me estuviese moviendo a una
velocidad constante mi posición como
función del tiempo sería una línea recta
verdad de hecho la velocidad en realidad
es la pendiente pero supongamos que
tengo una variación en la velocidad y en
realidad por ejemplo si estás
conduciendo un auto pues lo vas haciendo
no vas cambiando de velocidad así que
digamos que al tiempo cero empiezo en
cero después aceleró digamos que
desacelera un poco
digamos sigo desacelerando desacelerando
y después llega una parada así que aquí
me quedo luego aceleró otra vez
desaceleró acelero etcétera ok
así que esto podría ser digamos tengo
una variable velocidad y esto podría ser
mi posición en función del tiempo así
que todo esto es
tiene digamos este es el tiempo cero y
la posición cero entonces digamos esto
aquí es después de una hora y digamos
que he recorrido 60 millas
digamos aquí 60 millas
ok
y qué podemos decir podemos decir que mi
velocidad media
a velocidad media
es la distancia dividida entre el tiempo
recorrido que en este caso son 60 millas
por hora ok así que lo que dice el
teorema del valor medio es que la
velocidad media así que puedes verla
como la pendiente media entre este punto
y este otro punto si tu velocidad media
es 60 millas por hora habría cierto
punto en el tiempo quizás haya más donde
estaba yendo a exactamente 60 millas por
hora ahora todo tiene sentido verdad si
tu media son 60 millas va a haber algún
otro punto en donde justo tendrías una
velocidad instantánea de 60 millas así
que déjame ver si para dibujarlo
gráficamente digamos si este es la
pendiente de la velocidad media digamos
aquí digamos que también iba a 60 millas
por hora en este punto
de hecho hasta tengo otro no por ejemplo
éste
ok ahora antes de irme vamos a hacer
esto analíticamente digamos para hacerlo
con números vamos a la razón por la que
no me gusta y si me gusta el teorema del
valor medio es que después es útil si te
vuelves un experto matemático y
seguramente lo usarás para demostrar
teoremas o incluso demostrar hasta el
mismo problema pero si en cursos
normales de cálculo que no son tan
avanzados no lo vas a utilizar mucho así
que bueno bueno es interesante en ese
aspecto aprendes algo del mundo pero
bueno supongamos que tenemos la función
f x igual a x cuadrada menos 4x
así está bien y digamos que está
definido en un intervalo cerrado de 2 a
4 muy bien y entonces el teorema del
valor medio dice que si esta función
está definida en este intervalo podemos
poner cualquier número digamos el
dominio son en realidad de intervalos
cerrados en este caso verdad
pero bueno por lo como se define en este
intervalo en realidad esta función es
continua derivable existe todas las
derivadas en fin
el teorema del valor medio se aplica
aquí vamos a ver para qué valor de c es
igual a la pendiente media entre 2 y 4
entonces cuál es la pendiente media
entre 2 y 4
bueno pues va a ser efe de 4
efe de 4 - efe de 2 evaluado entre oops
evaluado en 2 y dividido entre 4 -2 muy
bien entonces
efe de 4 es 16 - 4 por 4 0 y luego efe
de 12 2 al cuadrado 4 - 2 x 4 es 8
entonces es menos
que dijimos
- menos 2 al cuadrado es 4 menos cuatro
por 28 a ésta
muy bien ahora dividimos todo esto sobre
dos y entonces qué nos queda esto es 4
sobre 2 que es la pendiente media por lo
tanto es 2 esto es igual a 2 muy bien
ahora el significado del teorema del
valor medio nos cuenta que debe haber un
punto entre estos dos entre 2 y 4 donde
la pendiente en este punto es
exactamente igual a 2 muy bien vamos a
averiguar qué punto es este entonces
hacemos la derivada la derivada de f
para dar a efe prima de x igual a 2x
menos 4 y queremos averiguar para qué
valor de x esto es igual a 2 entonces
decimos que 2x menos 4 es igual a 2 de
dónde
x es igual bueno tenemos que 2x es igual
a 4 más 26 y entonces x es igual a 3 muy
bien entonces si x es igual a 3 la
derivada es exactamente igual a la
pendiente media ahora voy a ver si puedo
hacerlo con una calculadora gráfica aquí
vamos a ver si la puedo poner en
en la pantalla ok entonces aquí tenemos
la gráfica de x cuadrada menos 4x vamos
a ver esto más grande
entonces el intervalo que nos importa es
de 2 a 4
entonces la pendiente media sobre este
intervalo era 2 no si hubiéramos
dibujado aquí la pendiente más o menos
parecería esta recta y entonces en el
punto 3 la pendiente también es
exactamente 2 voy a ver si puedo
dibujarla no es muy difícil de dibujar
por uno mismo verdad es en realidad una
parábola vamos a ver
entonces si este es el eje de las 10
este este vamos a pintar lo vamos a
quitar es y este es el eje el eje de las
x
entonces la gráfica pasa por el punto 00
verdad vamos a hacer hoy no esto no no
están bien hecho
a ver gráficamente se parece a esto no
se achata por aquí muy bien y luego hace
así entonces en realidad se sigue hacia
arriba esto es una parábola este es el
punto cuatro el punto dos está aquí
y en dos vale menos cuatro verdad dijo a
lo mejor está mal más las escalas pero
bueno buscamos la pendiente media en el
intervalo cerrado 24 lo que nos importa
es en este intervalo ok
este es el intervalo de dos a cuatro la
pendiente media es dos digamos no digo
no lo parece porque comprime un poco el
eje y es verdad entonces en el punto x
igual a tres que sí más o menos aquí la
pendiente vale lo mismo vale lo mismo es
a esa la pendiente de media verdad
seccional o mejor un poco complicado
hablar de continuidad de deriva bilidad
y todo eso pero lo que dice es que hay
algún punto entre estos dos del
intervalo donde la pendiente instantánea
o la derivada en ese punto es igual a la
pendiente media entre estos dos puntos
espero no haberte hecho un lío